bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france dont la guinée
est suspendue de la cedeao
après donc ce coup d'état dimanche
dernier dans ce timing justement est-ce
que c'est cohérent ou pas la décision
qui intervient quelques jours après le
coup d'état
la coupe ne mène la décision que pendant
que vient de prendre la cedeao je sais
pas si vous m'entendez on vous entend
ok si vous avez remarqué c'est une
décision a minima parce que la cedeao
est actuellement très mal placé sur la
situation qui viennent d'autant plus
qu'ils ont eu toutes les alertes depuis
2018 notamment depuis 2010 neuf romans
du projet de référendum elle est restée
inactive je pense que les décisions
qu'elles viennent de prendre ce sont des
décisions militaires s'est vu dirais
même le logiciel habituel c'est pourquoi
au niveau du centre d'analysé on avait
fait une autre la cedeao depuis l'année
dernière pour leur dire qu'au delà de
l'appui technique et financier au delà
d'avoir des observateurs il est temps
que cette institution repenser son
logiciel sur les processus électoraux en
guyane afrique et notamment sur les
changements constituent aujourd'hui qui
sont source du coup d'état le coup
d'état constitutionnel je pense que la
cédéao a bien réfléchi en disant qu'il
n'est inutile aujourd'hui d'infliger des
sanctions un homme comme au mali à la
guinée parce qu'elle met les
responsables cette situation alors c'est
pas vous citer le mali puisque on est un
peu dans un scénario similaire au mali
puisque là aussi le mali avaient été
suspendus il y avait une mission au site
avait été dépêchée par la cedeao à
bamako il ya une omission qui doit donc
se rendre aussi à conakry mission de la
cédéao vous dites qu'il faut changer de
logiciel mais est ce que c'est vraiment
possible au compte tenu de la
composition justement deux des membres
de cette institution ouest africaine
composée principalement de chefs d'état
des pays d'afrique de l'ouest
bien que les vénérables parce
qu'aujourd'hui si on voit ce qui s'est
passé au mali en guinée en côte d'ivoire
au togo au bénin c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui
la cedeao telle qu'elle est constituée
elle ne répond plus aux besoins de
démocratie dans ces différents pays donc
il est temps par exemple que réorganise
complètement la commission de la cedeao
à ne permettant plus à des
fonctionnaires ou des anciens ministres
ou des anciens militaires comme le pdt
les acteurs de la commission bêtement il
devait donc dans ce cadre là changer
complètement les attributions et le
recrutement au niveau de la commission
parce qu'il est temps aujourd'hui pour
qu'on instaure un vrai ladeveze pas le
droit dans ces pays que la cedeao se
dote d'un instrument permettant de
suivre les processus électoraux au lieu
uniquement de faire des appuis
financiers et des appuis envoie des
observateurs il le temps aujourd'hui et
là aussi c'est aussi valable pour
l'union africaine parce que les deux
institutions ont suivi de très près
c'est que s'est passé en guinée elles
sont restées inactives alors il ya cette
mission qui avait dépêché à conakry
comment à votre avis vont réagir les
militaires qui ont pris le pouvoir après
le coup d'état est-ce que ça va vraiment
ouvrir des négociations pour permettre
d'instaurer un processus de transition
moi je pense que la commission qui doit
arriver en guinée doit tirer les leçons
comme je disais tout à l'heure de
l'inaction qu'elle n'a lui mais surtout
elle doit aujourd'hui où les bleus à 200
kg au lieu de brandir des sanctions
parce que la sanction minimale elle
devait écouter l'analyse faite par les
nouvelles autorités guinéennes quand
sanguinet et cdo qu'on puisse mettre un
calendrier est un processus permettant
de revenir très rapidement un autre
concessionnaire à mon avis il n'est venu
la situation en guinée est complètement
différente de celle du mali il est
inutile de presser les nouvelles
autorités guinéennes d'organiser des
élections dans un délai à minima parce
que le mal est profond
monsieur alpha condé a eu dix ans pour
vraiment fracturé ce pays aussi bien sur
le plan social sur le plan économique et
sur le plan politique
donc je pense qu'il faudra que les
autorités de la cedeao prennent langue
avec les autorités la nouvelle recrue
kevin est pour quand sam ils définissent
un système un processus et des principes
pour permettre à la guinée enfin de
sortir de cette léthargie mais ces
violences politiques qui ont aujourd'hui
plombée complètement ce pays pour
excuser moi de ce thème parce que je
trouve
justement la cedeao qui demandent aussi
la libération d'alpha condé on connaît
la proximité de l'ex président à guinée
avec les chefs d'état qui composent donc
la cedeao est ce qu'il va être exfiltré
à votre avis alpha condé quels sont les
scénarios possibles pour lui
c'est d'abord je suis j'ai été très
satisfait que quand tu n'es pas eu
exercé des violences sur la personne du
président alpha condé j'étais des
retraites tout comme beaucoup de jeunes
des images que j'ai vues mais là à mon
avis il a hissé le résultat le centre
d'entêtement mais il serait quand même
découvrir c'est dommage pour la justice
pour les victimes que monsieur alpha
condé soit exfiltré de la guinée il
faudra absolument qu'on lui trouve les
garanties d'un procès pour qu'il puisse
s'expliquer sur ce qui s'est passé en
guinée sur tout tout tout ce temps
braille de violence et sans compter sur
le domaine économique de la corruption
n'y a jamais eu le niveau de corruption
était de telle sorte durant ces
dernières années c'est du jamais vu en
afrique de l'est plus donc on la lui
garantir un procès équitable et les
cultes et de la guinée c'est de donner
un signal fort pour tous ceux qui demain
ou après demain seront comptables ou
auteurs de violences je pense que la
cédéao et l'union africaine doivent
revue car m exactement comme monsieur
liste établie
au sénégal je pense cela est possible en
guinée une dernière question rapidement
elle avait dû elle loue baril et la
guinée conakry dont qui renoue avec les
coups d'état puisque alpha condé c'est
quand même une parenthèse qui permettait
aux pays de de se stabiliser et il ya ce
retour des coups d'état comme on
expliquer cette tradition de coup d'état
dans ce pays
alors quand même c'est que s'est produit
dimanche dernier à conakry c'est un
câlin mêmes faits historiques c'est que
si vous vous souvenez les derniers du
coup d'état qui a eu lieu en guinée
c'est des coups d'état comme d'air la
population la peine des coups d'état sur
un cada salle il a fallu la mort de
monsieur sékou touré pour que l'armée
s'empare du pouvoir et l'a fallu la mort
de lansana conté pour que l'armée se
sent capable pouvoir si aujourd'hui
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de ce pays qu'un président en exercice
de ses fonctions et sans violence si
vous avez remarqué on n'a pas du tout
attenter à sa personne et je pense que
vu toutes les violences qui ont eu lieu
en guinée qui n'y a jamais eu de justice
il est temps qu'on se serve de cette
situation pour permettre à la guinée de
commencer à tirer les leçons par un
procès juste et équitable afin que
d'abord les victimes soient rétablis
dans dans l'autre mais je serai ce
serait quand même dommage pour l'afrique
pour la cedeao que monsieur kalt en
berne en europe à ne pas boire la
justice dz la situation qui la provoque
en guinée merci à vous mamadou aliou
barry chercheurs directeur du centre
d'analysé d'études stratégiques